g2 just pulled off one of the most
insane lower bracket runs that european
league has ever seen to become spring
champions now they'll be heading off to
msi to face the rest of the world's best
teams but there's one team in particular
that they've called out using a pen and
their manager's leg let me explain
why would you look at that it's a league
of legends video on this channel and i'm
not talking about tsm if you enjoyed
that and you haven't subscribed please
consider doing so we're on the way to
two million subscribers and you could
definitely help us get there so once
again g2 our kings of europe now if you
tuned in during the last set of games
you might have thought the playoffs have
been a breeze for g2 but you couldn't
have been more wrong they initially got
slapped 3-1 by their old rivals fanatic
and sent packing down to the losers
bracket and from there they had a
mountain to climb they needed to win
three best of fives just to make it to
the grand finals and this wasn't a g2
that had dominated the regular season by
any means they finished fourth behind
rogue fanatic and misfits but they
comfortably three owed vitality and
their own former star player perks
before doing the same to misfits to set
themselves up for another showdown with
fnatic in the lower bracket final
remember just two weeks before fnatic
had quite comfortably beaten g2 but
nobody seemed to tell g2 that because
yet again they pulled off the 3-0
incredibly they were now in the grand
finals against the pretty scary rogue
they had now three-owed three teams in a
row surely this had to be more
challenging for them right trying to
defend they got a man advantage but what
can they do the shock bus goes wide caps
still advancing flash charge
it perfect play by the support from
the death from below
is enough
and the death of rogue is
[Applause]
that's right g2 were not only champions
for the ninth time they had won 12
individual games on their way to the
grand finals something just seemed to
click when they got kicked down to that
lower bracket but look if you tuned out
as soon as the game finished you missed
something pretty huge after the win we
saw broken blade crossing out rogue on
the leg of roman bija who's their
general manager and mascot but as we saw
more of the leg an uncrossed out name
was revealed t1 yes t1 the korean
powerhouse that had just completed a
record setting 18-0 perfect split
something that had never been done
before of course this was a team effort
kira gumiyushi owner zeus they've proven
themselves to be a level above the
competition they're just insane but a
lot of the focus has been around their
mythical mid laner faker partly because
well he's faker but he's also the only
remaining member of the 2015 team that
set that initial record for consecutive
wins you know what else he's the only
remaining member of 2019's skt the team
that later changed their name to t1 the
team that went to msi that year with
their heads held high but were upset by
a little european team known as g2 g2
went on to win the whole thing but skt's
pain wasn't over yet at worlds later
that year they dominated their group and
demolished europe's splice in convincing
fashion but once again they found
themselves up against g2 and once again
g2 crushed faker's dreams this g2
esports team
was not built to win
it was built to conquer
it had to go through so many obstacles
they had to fight every korean team on
the way here griffin in groups down one
in quarters and the ultimate final boss
of skt in the semi-finals and they
overcame the more caps and yankos are
the only two remaining members of that
legendary roster which also had perks in
the bot lane it's not been an easy ride
for g2 since then 2020 was a success but
last year they began to slip they came
third in spring and a distant fourth in
summer this meant they failed to qualify
for worlds for the first time in the
orgs history now some people said that
teams like mad lyons or rogue had just
caught up to g2 nothing lasts forever
others blame roster moves perks left g2
for cloud9 and was replaced by reckless
now on paper bringing the fnatic legend
in seemed like a match made in heaven
but it's safe to say that didn't work
out g2 blew up that roster and brought
in broken blade flackhead and targamas
2022 have been fairly rocky for them up
to this point exemplified by them
scraping into playoffs qualification and
then getting immediately knocked down to
the lower bracket but as you've probably
gathered from this video they are
currently european champions so
obviously something is going right there
as well they just need to find their
consistency one way to shut the doubters
up would be to go far at msi make europe
proud we've still got a few weeks till
the tournament begins but already the g2
t1 trash talk has begun kayla i watched
yesterday lc files but i even saw that
that thing at the end they strike all
their opponents one by one and also
understand at the end
make europe proud again he has said we
already analyzed g2 you know what that
means
[Music]
that they think about us who knows maybe
they'll knock out t1 once again but as
the old saying goes fall faker wants
shame on him fool him twice and god help
us all uh last time you met tijuan and
faker it didn't go so well for him so
how hyped should we be about g2 facing
up this time around i mean we're
definitely to take down vega
but
he did this in korea so they have the
the the home crowd uh hopefully some of
you guys can come cheers on as well if
possible um but we did defeat him last
time but that also means that he's
probably angry and i'm i know that angry
[ __ ] can be quite scary
i bought this haircut to be exactly
halfway between my last haircut and
when i take my vacation i literally like
looked on the calendar and i was like
that's the day that's the halfway point
between the two which is a bit
ridiculous but listen it's efficient
it's cost effective right